you know be lying there about artificial
womb saying yeah like we wanted we
wanted
to but outside of western um societies
like women know their place whilst yeah
i i agree because in this society
women
i feel like women they overdo it like
the thing is i believe everybody has
their place like she said and we all add
value but right now it's like oh you
said she's not pretty she's not pretty
yeah and now everyone's crying or you
said you can't you cannot cook that's a
basic necessity for your husband or for
you to have a you can't do it or i i
won't do nothing for a man that i'm not
married
and it's it's like who how much
your kids have to eat
the church do promote that you don't do
things for a man before you're married
to him well yeah but that's why like
they have single women in the church
yeah i think the church keeps
i mean and they and they tell virgins to
rebrand themselves and this non as a
born-again virgin that's not my church
it's a thing though did they have
chastity speakers
no you didn't have my pastor's a realist
he knows he knows that people are living
their lives yeah but i know what you're
talking about like because when i was
when i was in high school they would
always send i went to catholic school so
yeah they would they would always bring
in a chastity speaker and it was always
the same dynamic it was the girl that's
been ran through and then found god
conveniently and only did that stuff
because she was just you know pressured
and she just felt so broken whatever not
not i don't know horny
and the man is the he saved the day you
know he he swooped in
and now they make a living by her going
around saying she used to be hoe and
it's not over for the hose even though
it is over for a lot of laughing
yeah oh my god
there's a lady
there's a piece of promise movement oh
okay go ahead yeah so
my
though when we spoke about um cheating
we mentioned that men and women cheat at
similar rates
so then what what's worse like who's
worse for cheating is it man or woman
you see i
i think emotional cheating
i feel like for me that's whoever said
you should get money for feel like it's
true i've watched your thing everyone
says i feel like i feel like emotional
cheating is worse to me because i feel
like you are more invested
your emotions you're spending time with
her you're just sexual cheating oh
sexual cheating yeah i'm gonna like you
boys take the cup for that let's not do
that no
you think it's worse from like like
what's worse i feel like in this day and
age i feel like people are on par i feel
like men and women are on par
do you think do you think do you think
cheating is the same men for women men
and for women oh no as in okay i think
everyone's cheating the same however in
society
what's more damage into relationships
a man a man would leave like jay the way
that and what's his name baby whatever
his name is because of a text back and
at the end of the day when you bruise a
man's ego even if that's the love of his
life he's leaving because all the mandem
are laughing at him let's start with you
yes i i think i think there's
outstanding i think men have more time
but i do think it's damaging when the
man cheats and the woman finds out
because then he starts assuming she's
going to do it and then
i think
i think so a man can a man can cheat get
away with it if nobody knows
a woman can cheat and she's done
if a man cheats and the woman knows and
stays and stays he's going he can't deal
with the fact that she stayed with him
so he starts manipulating blaming her
for the cheating and saying it's her
four whereas it's actually your nature
you cheated because you could have been
her fault
maybe i mean i mean in most
circumstances there's a reason there's
always a reason but there's times where
the manchester he just gets women
so question would you guys be willing to
share a guy
if if um he
would you guys be willing to share a guy
if he checked off all your boxes and he
took care of the bills if i wasn't
christian yeah
i was just gonna say that if i wasn't a
christian yeah
yeah but i'm gonna lie my mothers and
values are my beliefs
are you guys virgins i cannot do that
are you guys virgins
but it's just like it's almost like
picking and choosing right when
christianity benefits you
no but i feel like that's all religion
no one's perfect and you can't like
yeah i know but to say like like this
sexual thing like i'm not saying you're
saying it's okay but i'm saying like i
could do this one but he couldn't do
that like it's just women oftentimes
pick the double standards that like
benefit them and not the ones that don't
so wait the question is would you stay
with
them and you and the reason you said no
is you said because you're a christian
so i said if that's true are you a
virgin
because like why would he marry you if
you're not a virgin aren't you both
getting a bad deal do you guys actually
marry for virginia is that a thing no
but if like religiously religiously so
i'm saying like he's getting a bad deal
because i'm assuming right i just assume
over certain age girls aren't virgins
right and so he's getting a bad deal so
like in that case you'd get the benefit
but you wouldn't get any cost
fair enough i mean as a typical woman my
my thought process is how does it
benefit me so i came from a family where
my mum my my grandfather had two wives
they all lived in the house together and
the children everyone stayed in the
house and everyone gets along really
yeah okay
back home in nigeria okay um
and i could see how it benefited them
for that time i'm just like my question
is how would that benefit me now
yeah because i mean
you said you said okay you said you have
kids right i have one you have one kid
yeah and how old are you i'm 34. so
would you would you say that over a
certain age you got a lower quality of
guy interested
maybe i don't want to say i'm not trying
to disrespect no no
so i'm saying in this case you have you
have a man now what i would admit to is
i do attract a lot of married men okay
yeah i'll admit to that i do attract
married men whether i entertain it or
not
yeah it's a question what i'm saying so
in this case you would check all your
boxes because i'm sure so life-changing
like yeah like he's taking care of the
bills you don't you can't you can get
that trainer
because you don't got to work anymore do
you know what let me let me be real let
me have a thing if if he came to me and
said you know what this is what i'm
about give me the option to think about
it mm-hmm
i don't know what i'd say if i liked him
i might think about it okay but if i
didn't like him then he's coming with
i'll be like
who the hell are you to give me those
scenarios i think i'm selfish i don't
know if selfish is the word i just feel
like everyone deserves somebody for
themselves i feel like why can't like he
have someone for himself i don't think
anyone deserves anything i think if
you're a shitty person you don't deserve
love fair enough but i think i'm not
that shitty so
i just think personally
i think men cheat anyway so i think
that's behind my thought pro is like if
they're doing it anyway if you've come
to me and said this is how you move
i feel like i appreciate the fact that
you're telling me i could do it
i would love to okay questions would you
do it would you do it at 35 with a kid
no
what if what if what if okay i don't
know
right now
i don't think i could just because i
just feel like i would just want to be
loved and loved loved by one person and
i would want to give that to him all
your bills are being taken care of but
the bills might not matter
necessarily yeah each individual
realistically most people it will but
say all your boxes are ticked everything
whatever that is to you
everything's ticked but you've got it i
think one
one box would be that like i would want
you that's what i'm saying call it
selfish i would want you for myself and
then i know me i'm just gonna get
jealous i'm just gonna be upset so
there's no plane okay so by this logic
do you guys believe that sex is a duty
yes yes 100 yeah do you guys believe a
man has a right to cheat if